hey 42 here beneath the city of antp in
the heart of the world famous Diamond
District lies one of the most secure
vaults on Earth guarded by 10 high-tech
security systems in a building that has
its own private police force there's
probably nowhere better on planet Earth
to stash your valuables a belief that
was shattered at 700 a.m. on the morning
of the 17th of February 2003 when staff
at the Diamond Center arrived for work
to find the door of this so-called
impenetrable safe hanging wide open
piled high on the floor inside were more
than 100 safety deposit boxes empty
safety deposit boxes roughly half a
billion dollars worth of loot was stolen
making it by far the biggest diamond
heist in history even now 20 years later
questions remain as to exactly how it
was done somehow a crack team of Thieves
bypassed motion detectors heat sensors a
seismic alarm dual locking mechanisms
numerous CCTV cameras a magnetic fail
safe and much much more to pull off the
crime of the century in one of the most
heavily guarded buildings in the world
and at least one of them would have
gotten away with it if it wasn't for a
pesky salami sandwich this is the
mind-blowing story of The antp Diamond
Heist the most ingenious robbery in
history WTF fif for is the first book of
a mega series from Ania press that
reinvents the action genre with a fresh
and bold approach it's a fun blend of
James Bond the transporter and
Californication that will prove to be an
entertaining hit with both male and
female audiences author Mark alen Barker
has created a book here that the reader
doesn't have to work too hard to
understand yet it transports them into
someone else's exciting and dangerous
world it's brilliant fun clever and
witty escapism literature at its very
best and it's available to purchase on
Amazon right now the Link's in the
description the story revolves around
two Central characters William Trevor
Francis an unapologetically flawed
smoking and gambling FIFA H and his
equally talented Interpol counterpart
Monique lefor I've been loving reading
this book and I genuinely couldn't put
it down I liked that William Trevor
Francis is not your typical hero but you
just can't help but root for him because
he's just a good guy trying to do the
right thing like I said FIFA H is a
really fun book and I thoroughly enjoyed
it the characters are great it's clever
and witty the travel across Europe is
brilliant and if you're into fast
non-stop action with a Twist then this
book should definitely be on your list
it makes the perfect gift for the
holidays so go ahead and get your copy
of WTF FIFA hire right now on Amazon
it's available worldwide you'll find a
link in the description below and a big
thanks to AIA press for sponsoring this
video the single square mile that makes
up the antp Diamond District is one of
the most concentrated pockets of wealth
in the world almost 85% of the world's
rough diamonds have pass passed through
this District at one time or another and
between them the local Diamond
businesses turn over more than $50
billion per anom back in the year 2000
when hardened gem Thief Leonardo nototo
rented an office in the diamond
District's most famous building the antp
world Diamond Center he knew all about
the legendary Vault hidden in the
basement but despite his stored criminal
career starting from the age of six he
had no interest whatsoever in actually
rubbing the place after all trying to
break into an impenetrable safe is a
good way to get yourself arrested killed
or both probably not both for notab Boro
the world Diamond Center was simply a
convenient place to sell gemstones he'd
stolen in his native Italy it was a good
system one he had no intention of
changing that is until the summer of
2001 when he was approached by a shady
diamonds dealer with an unusual
proposition this de deep throat type
character obviously had Deep Pockets
because he offered notab boto €
100,000 just to give his opinion on
whether or not it would be possible to
rob the diamond Center's Vault notab
boto accepted on the spot confident it
would be the easiest 100 Grand he'd ever
made he already rented a safety deposit
box in a Diamond sense's Vault and had
been down there many times to stash his
stolen Jewels which is why he already
knew the answer to the mysterious man's
question could the Diamond sensor's
Vault be
robbed no no multiplied by no plus no to
the power of 90 no still if notaba
wanted to get paid he needed to
substantiate his St with something more
solid and so he undertook a little
reconnaissance mission armed of a sneaky
camera pen sticking out of his fancy
Italian Blazer pocket he went through
the entire process of getting into the
Vault snapping covert pictures of all
the security systems along the way and
there were quite a lot of them the
entrance to the Diamond Center is
protected by metal turn Styles and
access is only granted to those with a
valid ID card inside the corridors are
patrolled by guards from the building's
well staffed and heavily armed private
security Force the vault is buried two
stories underground and can only be
reached by passing through a security
checkpoint manned by yet more armed
guards if by some miracle a Plucky Thief
managed to bypass all of that there
would still be the small matter of
getting inside the Vault itself a
veritable be muff of reinforced concrete
and steel hidden beneath a three ton
door a door that's secured by two
different locking mechanisms a
four-digit combination lock with 100
million possible codes and an absolutely
bunkers foot long key designed to be
impossible to forge and a magnetic fail
safe that triggers an alarm if the door
is opened
unexpectedly oh yeah and then there are
motion heat and light sensors inside the
Vault itself all of which would be
triggered the moment someone stepped
inside not to mention the fact that all
the valuables are locked away inside
state-of-the-art safety deposit boxes
Each of which requires a unique key and
passcode to open so yeah it's like the
hardest mission for Metal Gear Solid
except I'm pretty sure they don't have a
giant killer robot down there nototo
left the Vault after his reconnaissance
mission more convinced than ever that
his earlier assessment was absolutely
true breaking into the Diamond Center
Vault was completely and utterly
impossible and that's exactly what he
told the Shady diamonds dealer as he
shared the images recorded by his spy
pen the man seemed to accept naoto's
conclusion and for 6 months that seemed
to be the end of
it but then the man got back in touch
out of the blue with an ominous request
he wanted to meet natoro at an abandoned
warehouse on the outskirts of Anor now I
don't know about you but if a known
criminal who'd recently paid me a 100
grand for basically nothing wanted to
meet in the middle of nowhere I'd
probably immigrate to Tahiti to live out
the rest of my days masquerading as a
cleaning lady called
Susan but not a bolo apparently
fashioned from Sterner stuff agreed at
the warehouse the diamond dealer came
clean he still wanted to break into the
Vault and he needed notabot too's help
then he led him inside where there was a
full-size replica of the Vault and
antichamber perfect down to the tiniest
detail inside the fake Vault were three
Italian men a crack team of some of the
best burglars in Europe and I can only
assume this diamonds dealer was a fan of
gyi films because they all had really
stupid nicknames first there was the
genius a specialist in disabling complex
alarm systems next was the monster a
giant of a man who also happens to be a
world-class lock picker and electrician
and finally there was the king of keys
an older gentleman who was if rumors
were to be believed the greatest key
forger in the whole of Europe later on
notab boto would add one of his
childhood friends to the crew who mostly
seems to have been brought on board to
help carry the loot he received the
shockingly Crea nickname Speedy but it
wasn't just all fake vaults and fancy
nicknames the diamond dealer had a plan
a plan that exploited two important
observations Noto had missed 6 months
earlier first whilst the vault's
multi-ad security system appeared
impenetrable when viewed as a whole the
individual systems it consisted of were
about to secure as a fart in a colander
and second the entire setup was
vulnerable due to a fatal floor a
classic firal exhaust port on the Death
Star situation you see the men in charge
of the Vault were so convinced it
couldn't be cracked that they gotten
sloppy and that sloppiness created
certain opportunities for example
despite being manned by a slick private
security Force they all clucked off
outside of regular office hours if the
thieves somehow got inside during the
weekend they would have almost two full
days to carry out the job but by the
time naab Boro left the warehouse that
evening he was convinced against all
expectations the unbreakable Vault could
be broken but there was plenty of work
to be done even for our team of
professionals it took a year and a half
to construct a plan that stood any
chance of actually working but by early
2003 they'd set a date on the 15th of
February they were going in the day
before not too paid a final visit to the
Vault armed with of all things a can of
woman's
hairspray once inside he waited till
nobody was looking then sneakily sprayed
a thin layer of the stuff on the wall in
one particular part of the Vault you'll
see why in a minute that night the crew
held a slightly less virtuous version of
The Last Supper being Italians they paid
a visit to the local Deli where they
ordered salami and Italian bread to make
what I can only assume were absolutely
bloody amazing sandwiches criminals or
not Italians don't mess around when it
comes to food unfortunately for one of
them that one Taste of Home would
directly lead to a prison
sentence but I'm guessing ahead of
myself late the following night Noto
dropped the crew off just outside the
Diamond District he was to be the
getaway driver but it all went to plan
there would be no need for high-speed
chases the first item on the crew's very
long to-do list for the weekend end was
to get inside the world Diamond Center
the front entrance was an absolute noo
it was locked down with steel shutters
and covered from all angles with CCTV
instead as planned the king of keys
picked the lock of a nearby empty office
building which gave them access to a
courtyard that backed on to the Diamond
Center from there they used a ladder to
climb up to a smaller Terrace on the
center second floor but there was a
small problem the Terrace was protected
by an infrared sensor that would trigger
the most moment it detected a heat
signature bigger than a pigeon it was a
high-tech piece of kit but the genius
defeated it with a laughably low Tech
hack he went up the ladder first
approaching the sensor whilst holding a
large shield made of poyene the same
stuff we make cheap disposable coffee
cups out of it's an excellent thermal
insulator and the shield completely
blinded the sensor to the genius's
presence once he was close enough he
simply propped The Shield up in front of
the the sensor and beckoned the rest of
the team up he then made short work of
an alarm protecting the window and they
were in as expected the entire building
was deserted so the thev strolled down
the emergency stairs and into the Vault
anti chamber completely unopposed the
anti chamber was flush with CCTV but
once again the security team had been
sloppy they turned the lights out
meaning the cameras were effectively
blind thanks to notab boro's
reconnaissance work the crew knew
exactly where all the cameras were so
they slipped thick black bin bags over
each one of them then turned the lights
on if anyone happened to be monitoring
the footage they would never know
anything was a mess so far the plan had
gone off without a hitch but now came
the hard part getting into the Vault
itself so any ideas how they did it if
you're expecting the monster to bust up
the power tools you're dead wrong cuz
Not only was the door protected by two
separate locking mechanisms and a magnet
magnetic fail safe the entire Vault was
also rigged up to a seismic alarm that
would trigger as soon as it detected
significant vibrations so brute forcing
it was just out of the question and if
they couldn't break into the Vault that
really left one option they were going
to have to open it the oldfashioned way
at some point dur the MS leading up to
the heist notab boto had somehow managed
to hide a tiny video camera above the
vault door positioned in the perfect
spot to record the guards as they oped
the safe each morning not only did that
give him the four-digit code for the
combination lock it also gave him high
resolution video footage of the
impossible to forge foot long key or
should I say the impossible to forge
unless you're called the king of keys
Foot Long Key the whole operation should
have hinged on whether or not the king
of keys had actually pulled it off but
once again it turns out the guards had
been sloppy because in a small room near
the safe the crew found the original key
just hanging on a random hook so both
locks were open the final hurdle that
needed vating before they got inside was
the magnetic fail safe which consisted
of two metal plates one on the door of
the Vault and the other on the frame
move these plates just a few millimeters
out of alignment and an alarm would
sound it was a high-tech mechanism but
once again it was defeated by a
ridiculously low Tech workaround the
alarm itself wasn't built into The Vault
it was a separate module that had been
bolted on so the thieves just unbolted
it with the locks open and the alarm
disabled the thieves were finally able
to get inside the Vault but here's where
things got a little hairy remember there
were three different kinds of sensors in
there light heat and motion the first of
those was easy the gang just turns the
lights back off before they went inside
and stuck a piece of tape over the
sensor but heat and motion just by
stepping inside the Vault and Bre
grieving a bit they would surely trigger
both but here's where naso's sneaky kind
of hairspray came to the rescue the Heat
and motion sensors are actually a single
unit that would only be triggered if
both movement and a rise in ambient
temperature were detected
simultaneously by spraying the sensor
with an oil-based aerosol Noto had
created a tiny insulating layer between
the air of the Vault and the sensor
preventing it from accurately measuring
the ambient temperature it wasn't a
perfect system ha spray or not sooner or
later all those sweaty Italians would
increase the temperature enough to
trigger the alarm but it was enough to
give them the time they needed if they
acted fast luckily the team had
rehearsed this next bit hundreds of
times in the replica Vault and they knew
exactly what to do working in Pitch
Darkness the monster took exactly 12
steps forward and then reached up and
removed a single ceiling panel right in
the center of the Vault inside side was
part of the wiring system for the
sensors as he had aund times before in
the replica the monster quickly
installed a loop in the system tricking
the sensors into thinking the safe was
empty and with that every single one of
the Vault safety features was now
properly disabled broken or
unlocked they were in well almost there
was still a minor inconvenience at every
single valuable item in the entire Vault
was locked inside a high-tech safety
deposit box but of course our band of
Merry salami loving thieves were well
prepared for that in fact since they
knew the exact make and model of the
boxes they'd gone to the trouble of
Designing a custommade tool to crack
them open for the next few hours that's
exactly what the king of keys
did he'd broken into more than
120 of the 160 safy deposit boxes before
the gang realized they were swimming in
so much loose they'd never be able to
get it all out out and that meant it was
time to go in the early hours of Sunday
morning the now heavily Laden thieves
snuck back out the way they'd come
stopping by The Diamond Center security
Hub to steal the CCTV tapes from the
central recording system they then threw
the loot in notor too's car and got the
hell out of there they still had a good
24 hours or so until anyone would
realize what had happened and they
planned to use that time for two
purposes one to get his far away from
antp as possible and two to dispose of
several bin bags full of Highly
incriminating evidence they' accumulated
during the planning and execution of the
heist that last part fell to nototo and
his old mate Speedy who were already on
their way to Terin but it was about it
this time that things started to go
wrong or to be more precise it was about
at this time that Speedy went wrong he
was a nervy character at the best of
times and apparently he wasn't adjusting
well to his new role as one of the most
Wanted men in Europe the original plan
had been to stop and burn the evidence
somewhere in France but Speedy was
having none of it he wanted to get rid
of anything that could link them to the
crime scene as soon as possible and so
before they'd even made it to Brussels
they pulled off the motorway and into
some Woods to get the job done trouble
was by this point Speedy was having a
full-blown nervous breakdown so instead
of systematically burning the contents
of the bag as planned he ran off into
the woods like a character from The
Blair Witch Project flinging the
contents of the bags all over the place
by the time notor too caught up with him
it was too late the evidence was
scattered so far and wide that there was
simply no chance of gathering it all up
again not that notoro was overly worried
they were in a nondescript tractor
Forest off a Motorway in the middle of
nowhere it would be months perhaps even
years before anyone came through that
way again and by that time the evidence
would have been consumed by the elements
unfortunately for him that assessment
turned out to be wild optimistic because
it was barely more than 12 hours before
someone stumbled across Speedy's
handiwork and fewer than 24 before the
police were combing through it it was
the beginning of the end in amongst the
litter were dozens of envelope stamped
with the words antp Diamond Center there
was also a receipt with naab bolo's name
on for a not at all suspicious sounding
miniature lowl light surveillance camera
and a business card belonging to a
well-known criminal with a knack for
alarms Elio dorio aka the genius and the
last piece of incriminating evidence was
a half-eaten salami sandwich maybe it
wasn't that amazing after all and when
the police showed up at noto's flat in
antp they found a receipt for exactly
that sandwich in one of the cupboards
like most receipts this one included
both the name of the deli it was from
and the amp all the police had to do was
request the shop C CCTV footage at that
particular time and they got themselves
their first look at Ferdinando fenato
AKA The Monster as the evidence mounted
one by one those involved were arrested
well all except for the king of keys he
was never caught and is presumably right
now swimming in a bathtub full of Grey
Goose vodka and prostitutes on his
private island in the South Pacific
despite the magnitude of their crime
most of those involved received
relatively short sent sentences the
genius the monster and Speedy each Got 5
years for their troubles though all
three of them were released long before
their time was up notab Boro got a
slightly more reasonable sound in 10
years but he was released on parole
after four to this day almost none of
the stolen goods have been
recovered as for the mysterious Diamond
dealer who set the whole thing up like
the king of keys he was never caught in
fact people believe he never even
existed and that either nototo was the
criminal mastermind all along or that
perhaps he made the diamonds dealer up
to conceal the identity of someone else
the most popular theory is that it may
have been his cousin benedetto capizzi a
senior figure in the Italian mafia but
in all likelihood we'll never know for
sure it goes about saying that stealing
millions of dollars from other people is
morally suboptimal but it's hard not to
admire the sheer Ingenuity of the
thieves who pulled off the antp diamond
Heist and whilst it was an unambiguously
evil act perpetrated by some Highly
Questionable characters when you think
about it there's actually quite a
powerful lesson here if in life you ever
happen to be faced with a seemingly
insurmountable challenge don't give up
break the problem down into smaller more
manageable chunks and keep on trying no
matter how hard it seems and no matter
the odds and you never know you might
even end up becoming a millionaire just
stay away from the salami thanks for
watching just a quick word to say that I
couldn't make these videos without the
support of my patreon members consider
joining the exclusive 42 Discord
Community by supporting me on patreon
it's a great place to discuss my videos
with like-minded individuals and myself
the Link's in the description but if you
don't want to or you can't join my
patreon then please don't worry a simple
like or comment to say thanks would also
put a huge smile on my face thank you